thanks to brilliant for sponsoring this
video
[Music]
recently europe has been a little bit on
fire i mean that both literally and
figuratively in the sense of there being
widespread heat waves i've actually
already made a video about those these
heat waves have understandably sparked a
lot of discussion
about why this is happening and a
particular argument that's come up time
and time again on my feeds has been that
this isn't actually a problem because
england used to be warmer in the
medieval period than it is now well if
that's the case then this current
warming trend is nothing to worry about
as it's just within the past variations
of european climate but how do we know
this is the case where's the evidence
for what's called the medieval warm
period we don't have temperature records
going that far back because thermometers
hadn't been invented yet then so
scientists use proxy measurements that
is an indirect measurement of something
by measuring something else i explained
how these work in a fair bit more detail
in a video about how the man at our
hockey stick is the wrong shape so go
watch that for more info if you're
interested so what are the proxy
measurements that tell us england used
to be warmer in the medieval warm period
firstly vineyards england is known for
ale and cider these days not wine but in
the doomsday book
there are around there's a little bit of
uncertainty 50 vineyards listed compare
that to the only eight vineyards that
apparently existed in this country in
the 19th century as winemaking is so
highly dependent on climate and we see
so many more vineyards in for example
much warmer france it stands to reason
that england was much warmer at the time
of the doomsday
secondly however trees a more accurate
measure of past climate can be obtained
by looking at tree ring data the field
known as dendroclimatology
love that name measuring the thickness
of individual tree rings corresponding
to how warm the growing season was in
that given year scientists have been
able to reconstruct what the average
temperature was like in years past and
look you can see this helpfully labeled
medieval warm period in england remember
this graph we'll come back to it so
based on these two measurements and
others it appears that england was
warmer in the medieval period than in
surrounding centuries and thus when
people talk about current warming it's
nothing to worry about it's nothing we
haven't already seen in the medieval
warm period well two problems with that
firstly a paper published in 2009 in the
journal science included this figure
showing the temperature anomaly during
the medieval warm period or as they
termed it the medieval climate anomaly
so red here means something is warmer
than the long-term average while blue
means colder than the long-term average
as you can see there's a big warm blob
in the north atlantic where the uk is
but looking at the rest of this map
there's a lot of blue on here so while
the uk was warmer around the year 1000
than the overall temperature record
average for much of the rest of the
world around the year 1000 it was
actually cooler than that average in
other words the warming was regional
there was no global temperature trend in
fact a decade later scientists writing
in the journal nature found that there
was no evidence for any temperature
changes such as a medieval warm period
or little ice age on a global scale
before the modern period quote the
warmest period of the past two millennia
occurred during the 20th century for
more than 98
of the globe
today we are seeing a rapid global
temperature trend unlike anything we've
seen in the past few thousand years of
the temperature record so while england
specifically was warmer around the year
1000 that wasn't the case everywhere
else again the warming was regional
secondly i don't think i have access to
a data set if one even exists that could
conclusively quantitatively say that
england was warmer during the medieval
period than now but you may ask what
about that tree ring data well that tree
data wasn't actually from england
despite being bandied around online as
english data for example here it's not
english or even british data it's from
scandinavia a location the authors of
the original paper this figure is from
note has experienced relatively little
warming this century this is misleading
data presentation it's downright
deception as professor rob wilson from
the university of st andrews notes there
are surprisingly few tree ring
temperature reconstructions from the
british isles and those that do exist
are difficult to interpret because there
are just so many overlapping factors
that determine tree growth in the
british isles temperature is just one of
them published temperature
reconstructions using tree rings instead
tend to be representative of the whole
northern hemisphere or at least a region
of it because using multiple tree sample
locations gives you much more confidence
in your temperature reconstruction and
those reconstructions look more like
this with no clearly defined warm or
cold periods but a definite uptick in
temperatures towards the present day
also to briefly return to the other
proxy measurement that i mentioned yes
in the doom
there are more english vineyards than in
the 19th century but nowhere near as
many vineyards as there are in the 21st
century there are over 400 english
vineyards operating now and they stretch
much further north than they are in the
doomsday book so by the logic of this
measurement that indicates that the
climate is warmer now than it was in the
medieval warm period but for the record
vineyards are terrible proxies for past
temperature there are just too many
variables all stacked on top of one
another like total precipitation and
number of frost-free days in spring that
determine if a vineyard is actually
feasible at a given location it's not
just the temperature based on the data
available then medieval england was
perhaps modestly warmer than iron age
england and renaissance england but not
warmer than the england we see today
most experts will tell you that the
warming we're experiencing today goes
beyond any natural climatic variation
and that we are currently seeing
temperatures that we've not seen in the
british isles for the past several
thousand years
you make me sad the main conclusion here
however is that the medieval warm period
such as it was
was a regional warming certain parts of
the planet including england were warmer
in the medieval period than in the
long-term temperature average and other
parts of the planet were cooler than
that long-term temperature average but
that regional warming was still a lesser
magnitude than the global warming
we see today
he said it he said it if you look at
global average tree ring data for the
past few thousand years then it's really
clear that the medieval warm period is
just not detectable and is dwarfed by
modern warming this graph really clearly
shows that what we're experiencing today
is not natural it's not something we've
seen before it's absolutely man-made and
it's worrying so if you see this
argument being made online you're a bit
more clued in now and specifically you
know that it's complete [ __ ] should
you wish to learn more about how
scientists talk about climate and
specifically some of the terminology
like regression and variance then i can
highly recommend the course on
statistics on brilliant who have kindly
sponsored this video brilliant is a
website and app designed to supplement
traditional education and introduce you
to new concepts in maths science and
computer science in a fun interactive
way they offer expertly written
gorgeously illustrated courses from
middle school to graduate school level
across a huge range of subjects
everything from pre-algebra to
computational biology and several
classes written in collaboration with
youtubers you may well know and love
such as kuskosak and my mate brian from
real engineering if you're in education
brilliant takes the concepts you're
learning about in school and brings them
to interactive life allowing you to have
a look at them from a different
perspective well if you've left
full-time education brilliant in
particular the app keeps your scientific
skills sharp and allows you to pursue
your scientific curiosity i cannot
recommend brilliant highly enough i've
worked with them for several years now i
love their philosophy when it comes to
education and i'm constantly impressed
by the new courses they honestly keep
getting better and better to get started
for free so there's really no excuse to
not do this visit brilliant.org simon
clark or click the link in the
description and the first 200 people to
do so will get 20 off brilliant annual
premium subscription for themselves or
for a student in their life with thanks
to brilliant for sponsoring this video
and for being you know brilliant
thank you so much for watching the video
i hope that you took something away from
this maybe this is a claim you've heard
before and hopefully this has cleared
things up for you if you did enjoy it
please do pop the video a like and let
me know what you thought down there in
the comments it really does help the
channel and if you'd like to watch
something next here's the recommended
viewing that just leaves me to say thank
you again for watching i'll see you in
the next one